gregor is last fight he came in as the
lucky happy leprechaun
i respect yay i respect the punches
of your hot sauce give me your sum up
hot sauce tonight respect ye
he did all that other [ __ ] it was a
little weird yeah a little weird to see
conor mcgregor not bring the fire in the
heat
tony robbins probably [ __ ] him up a
little bit why do you think he he pulled
that up like why do you think he was
like all nice
like with cowboy and then dustin i think
do you think he wants to be a different
in five four three
two one hello everybody
palabra my name
is milamo david so
[Music]
all right a little el drunko because we
drank a little too much
welcome to pirata podcast we have
nick the ear we also have patrick.t dot
riley we do what's up baby
my name is fully your name
we drank so much in the previous podcast
we're starting this one off
a little happy yeah this is the pirate
episode dude straight up
david i drank a little bit you know what
i mean my head is like
yeah kind of warm yeah two sips but it's
cool you know i drink the [ __ ] out of
that five percent beer homie yeah yeah
that's right you are a little red
already just from that one drink i'm
telling you i get [ __ ] up pretty easy
i'm a cheap date cheap date bro hey does
tiff ever take advantage of you in your
drunken state
touch your butt she tries she'll be
trying to touch my butt i don't know
what it is what girls
do you think yeah they think does meryl
do that too
mariel hates physical contact
whenever we have sex without me touching
her dude what happens you just don't
touch her at all so mario she just
so she didn't grow up with siblings
didn't grow up with people like kind of
[ __ ] around with her or anything like
that
so like physical touch is very like uh
what's it called
special so when we first started going
out i used to like try to grab her ass
and she's like don't do that i'm like
but i'm your boyfriend
yeah yeah if i can't grab your ass who's
asked am i gonna grab yeah i started
grabbing all the homeboys
but she didn't she didn't allow it at
first she finally allows it after seven
years
wow you know tiff was kind of like that
too when we first started dating she
wasn't really into physical touch but
over the years she kind of like
whoa yeah she was like she was like into
it you guys have mad patients
into a dog you guys have patience well
you love the people you love
you know what i mean you can't help who
you fall in love with you could just you
could just grab up on your lady whenever
you want
honestly she's more like that to me she
treats you like a piece of meat all the
time they're like
don't leave me what
oh yeah that i'll be like bro i'm trying
to [ __ ] read she's over here [ __ ]
like
oh yeah you [ __ ] [ __ ] do something
why did you make me stop [ __ ] i live in
a jail cell bro
this [ __ ] always trying to touch my
butthole reggie bro i'm always trying to
look like
she has manifested himself into sarah
she says she sets up like home alone
traps like little marbles and [ __ ]
i'll be like stumbling and she just dies
she tries to catch the angle like credit
cards my ass is
yeah you a hot commodity bro you hot in
these streets how'd you meet your lady
uh we work together actually oh this
full can't keep business and pleasure
separate dude you [ __ ] smell
good how do you do it what will she do
tell me how you don't do that
that's what i want that's the story i
want to hear how do you work with
somebody and you're around
all the time and like you can't you're
always like you're here for
six seven hours the majority of
relationships outside of high school
happens within the workplace or small
groups like that bro i hear grocery
stores people be [ __ ] in there
i believe it like i believe members they
just be busting with everybody
the old ladies look like freaks in there
all the time the bonds ladies and
gentlemen
[ __ ] they got the little sparkle in
their eyes they're a little too happy
yeah you play monopoly hey playing on
the parka place
yeah they're crazy though they're crazy
where are your melons you know where
they're at
right here yeah show me where your
celery stops apron baby
let's make some juices you want that
organic [ __ ] people just trying to get
some of my pants alone
you gotta let people get their nuts off
you just got people are gonna [ __ ] you
know
that's what we do you get people
together they're gonna [ __ ] people [ __ ]
eventually everybody in the workplace
[ __ ] everybody dude
everybody [ __ ] i feel like restaurants
specifically though are like are just
[ __ ] breathing well i mean it's the
perfect area to flirt dude it's like
super high paced you're talking to
everybody you can make your cute little
jokes here and there go back to work
come back flirt again yeah
super fun like school like school that's
why school was so dope because like
did your period you had all your years
did you move on her she made the move on
you
uh she made the move what was her move
how did she do it aggressive
yeah she seems to grow up just like pull
your [ __ ] pants down [ __ ] boy
i don't see that
dick give me what you're working with
she was like mommy's gonna get her nut
[Applause]
whip that dangling out mommy's
[Laughter]
yeah she doesn't let you finish she just
gets her nut and leaves and that leaves
you she cleans yourself up see that
video of that girl in like public
[ __ ] fingering the [ __ ] out of
herself
no but what the [ __ ] what yeah what was
that
that's the premium subscription when you
say the hub everyone's like yeah i know
that place you gotta pay for that one
that's the star one right there
yo this is the premium
i'm talking about juice everything she
squirted
what this girl's nuts is on twitter
twitter twitter shows crazy [ __ ] though
honestly why is she doing that is she
[ __ ] up she's just finger blasting
i'm pretty sure she's [ __ ] up on some
[ __ ] it's got to be does she have a
multiple personality disorder i don't
know but she's actually
like now she's twerking dog it's like
wet on the floor bro
though bro that'll [ __ ] up a vibe real
quick
and they kicked her out oh there's some
tickle bitties bouncing around on the
cheetah dress
she's really cute what is wrong with
that yeah she had to be on some [ __ ]
yeah yeah she [ __ ] up you straight
finger blast oh my god this is great
people are walking around
it's a shaky cam like a cloverfield
camera
it's bringing the [ __ ] out monster's
arrived this goes
and that monster is squirting because
you know what's so weird though it's
like if a guy was doing this that dude
would be
[ __ ] harangued because nobody wants
to see that oh yeah nobody wants to see
a guy jerking off yo yeah
it's just because i think there's just
also too many dudes already jerking off
yeah this is a rarity that's rare yeah
that's a novelty that's like gyarados
mythical pokemon gyarados
what the [ __ ] that's a [ __ ] zapper
she's a mewtwo
when you see one you know oh my god
you're not [ __ ] nuts though yeah
she willing bro i've never ever seen
some [ __ ] like this dude that's crazy
what do you say to that what do you do
today don't say
i just go cheer her on you know
get it you [ __ ] security took way too
long to get over there because they were
like yo this is really fingering
yourself
they were like wow no they didn't
normally bias too that's what they call
it yeah
what does that mean normally bias
happens when you
it's literally you see things in a
normal state so that's what your brain
is trying to configure
right so for example when you see
somebody get robbed a lot of people
react late
because of two things there's normalcy
bias and also bystander effect right so
bystander effect is you
expect everybody else to do something
normalcy bias is that you're you're
trying to compute what you normally see
in the world so you
your brain fries gotcha it's like oh
this is normal
yeah somebody just got jacked that
happened to me that makes sense actually
that doesn't make sense that [ __ ] was
crazy i was picking up tiffany outside
of work one day and
paseo at the old town or whatever and
this this our meet this big ass armenian
dude he
pulled up behind me in a car because i
was waiting in my car he walks out
he goes into a jewelry store and then
two minutes later you see him running
back out and the
the store owner is chasing him he's like
he stole my [ __ ] he stole my [ __ ]
and he got the big armenian gets in his
car they're wrestling in the front seat
of his car he's in the passenger seat
the store owner is like trying to get
grab a [ __ ]
he pulls out a snapple bottle and the
car is like
driving away dips the [ __ ] out and he
throws the snap a bottle at the car
because the guy stole a bunch of these
watches and he just dipped out and i was
like yo
what the [ __ ] and i was like in my head
i was like was i supposed to do
something i was like what the [ __ ] was i
supposed to do
exactly what are you like even if you
were gonna do something right
it's just you don't you're trying to
figure out what the [ __ ] is going on
exactly you don't know the context
yeah right and everybody too they go if
i was there all right
bro you wouldn't got it same thing i was
in front of a jamba juice the one in
past
in south pass right saw a dude great job
jacked right in front of
thomas i literally watched it all go
down and i went
wait yeah yeah yeah that's real
and i was like oh [ __ ] he already stole
it bro you're done mm-hmm it's it's
stolen
what are you gonna do what do you crime
stop her you're not everyone's expecting
you to do anything ten more minutes i
would have stopped them
oh yeah bro i'm gonna make some time to
process this yeah i was told hey man
give me a sec i have normalcy bias right
now don't leave it don't leave nowhere
i got to figure this whole thing out
what's the context still what do you do
to you who's stealing from who
what's happening there was that [ __ ]
uh carnival ride thing where you see it
where it's about to tip over oh yeah
yeah and then a bunch of people just ran
up and put their weight on it so it
doesn't tip over yeah that was ballsy of
those people who would have thought that
to do that
i don't know but the at first at the end
of the video it's like
30 people but in the beginning it was
just like two [ __ ] like just
trying to hold it down
amazing for the first two [ __ ]
that were because it was them for a
while yeah
because my reaction would have been a
run too yeah i would have ran the [ __ ]
away i would have did
you can't do no disneyland level ride at
a carnival bro
yeah that's why you can't be doing this
i was just thinking about the people on
the ride like how terrified they was
they must have been freaking the [ __ ]
out they came down and there's a video
after where people they were crying and
hugging their boyfriend girlfriend
and they're like oh my god
i should have my died i make fun of it
but it was very sweet
dude that's funny as [ __ ] bro but we
gotta get into the topic at hand before
the conversation gets away with this
like the last one yeah
ufc which number 256 through 64. two
whenever the connor's on the card it's
always a banger of a show
except for running that card was [ __ ]
i don't remember whatever
we'll just get into the meat of the
conversation then we'll talk about the
other fighters because everybody knows
who
who [ __ ] conor mcgregor is right
[ __ ] [ __ ] crazy weigh-in super super
aggressive so everybody
you know who conor mcgregor is last
fight he came in as the lucky happy
leprechaun
i respect ye i respect the punches
of your hot sauce give me your sum of
hot sauce tonight respect yee yeah he
did all that other [ __ ]
it was a little weird yeah a little
weird to see conor mcgregor not bring
the fire in the heat
tony robbins probably [ __ ] him up a
little bit why do you think he
he pulled that off like why do you think
he was like all nice like with
cowboy and then dustin i think do you
think he wants to be a different guy
do you think he doesn't want to be this
trash talker i think i think
genuine i think for him he's getting
older
he's a dad yeah i think that's part i
think it's his natural evolution
i think now the regressing back to the
crazy dude
was in part because of the the charity
[ __ ] yeah so he i think genuinely he was
pissed do you feel like he's about to
do that to get in
other fighter's head do you feel like
that's what he feels deep down i don't
think so because all these pundits were
saying like oh he gotta get back to the
old connor
karate stands come on he has to be this
trash talking guy that's why he didn't
beat
dustin no because that was so much part
of his game right because
yeah but he was like with connor with
the cowboy he was nice and he [ __ ]
smoked him like super quick i know
cowboy is on a downward slide but still
like it's
he came out ferocious like it wasn't
like he wasn't it was like conor the
connor always comes out aggressive right
so if you evaluate the way he came out
in that fight he still came out
aggressive yeah and you know arguably
one too and you can't take dustin's a
[ __ ]
animal bro like he's he's probably he
should be the champ right now
100 percent he's the uncrowned champion
yeah he's an unground chapter so it's
not
like he's like it's easy to say that
like if he probably fought somebody else
he probably would have ran through him
too
you know he's fighting [ __ ] dust and
poiya but that dude's an animal
it's just so crazy because everybody
knows this but that fight ended
with conor mcgregor so basically what
happened was dustin poirier and conor
mcgregor both throw their left cross
they miss
when i first saw it i thought that
poirier cracked him they both moved
their head off center line
either one of them would have landed
that punch they were so
in range they both threw it with such
power double knockout
yeah like that would have been like a
knockout for sure
either of them because they were so
close and they threw it so hard
they literally had each other's timing
down like yeah
his [ __ ] tibia snaps on the lower
part of it
well this was crazy right because
everybody it like legit
shocking as [ __ ] because we've seen this
happen so often lately
yeah not just this past year yeah not
just in mma but like combat karate all
this other weird stuff and it's
happening a lot more and more frequently
and it's not a coincidence coincidence
that it's happening during the time that
the cat kick is becoming highly
popular right a lot of muay thai guys
are warning people about this too they
go there's a reason we don't kick at the
calf
right just because it's such a kick
heavy sport yeah and the reason why is
because there's such a high propensity
to hit shin on chin
it's just what it is but when you do a
full clip like the placement of those
calf kicks have to be
on point and yeah you know with
apparently i was looking i was watching
this uh
physical therapist and this doctor talk
about that injury that happened to his
lower um
shin bone as tibia and they were saying
that it's actually very common when
your foot is planted and there's
rotational force in your knee and your
hip
and that's pretty much what what
happened to you know obviously obviously
his shin was compromised up until that
point
but they were saying that that type of
break is very common when a lot of force
is
kind of being thrown from the leg into
the ground
up into the hip and stuff you know so
when i saw that
the way it buckled as he rotated as soon
as he threw that i was like oh [ __ ] his
[ __ ] is broken
yeah you know cause his foot [ __ ] oh
it was disgusting
but interestingly he didn't throw any
cat they were all thigh
ball thigh here's the weird thing so
there was a lot of people saying that it
was dustin poirier's elbow that cracked
the tibia
but what i so john wayne parr he
actually put up a video
where this couldn't have it could have
been the first time or who knows but
this is where you can see it on video
he actually kicked dustin poury in the
thigh and it was already broken yeah it
was already like loose it already
wobbled and then it snapped
back into place when he kicked off so he
probably felt the pain the adrenaline
rush was there but because
it it was a clean snap and it snapped
back into place he was able to land on
it
fine with the pain yeah and then
literally
he plants it super hard
and that's how you have to punch if you
want to land hard you got to use your
legs you got to rotate from the floor
your ankle knee hip to throw that cross
but also too it's like a lot of people
were like oh no he checked the kick but
there was no check
there was no check and all the kicks
that were landed were all on the thigh
yeah they landed strong
dustin was kind of like oh [ __ ] he
couldn't adjust to it anyway yeah he was
taking him but
the most likely thing that happened is
for me it's like
i think that during the training camp
obviously this part of there's a game
plan
whenever there's a leg break that
happens it probably happened from being
damaged
in the training camp yeah right and so
that's probably what happened he was
trying to
throw this a bunch of times yeah conor's
been in and out of the gym
this is it's he seems like right now
he's a guy
that with all the other stuff that he
has outside of the octagon he's only
training for fight camps
yeah right and when you're not a gym rat
like that you can't rush this process of
trying to harden your bones there's a
reason why these muay thai guys are
have some of the hardest shins of all
time because they're
[ __ ] in the gym every single day
kicking the bag kicking sandbags taking
whatever the [ __ ] they can bone on bone
all the time for that conditioning
you can't rush that conditioning and i
feel like for a guy like conor who's not
really known to be throwing low kicks
like that to the thigh at least
like roundhouse muay thai style where
it's a shatter on a thigh shows how
compromised it was yeah
i thought well you just got to think
about how many times in training to it
it got checked
yep because he's sparring guys that are
lit he probably brought in muay thai
dudes yeah yeah so you think
that was no check yeah doctor stoppage
yeah yeah yeah
you see it was crazy because thinking
about all the effort he put into this
fight camp
yeah for it to just shatter like that so
much was on
the line for this fight his legacy yeah
and we all kind of got robbed of
yeah including dustin we all got robbed
of
of a decisive finish i'll put it like
this right
standing up porya was getting cracked he
was getting cracked actually with those
low kicks he landed the more strikes
connor landed in the motion
and then even unconscious even on his
back
conor land has some great elbows
so we definitely got robbed of a great
fight right sure
and i'm pretty sure a lot of people who
are dust and pourier fans or like it
wouldn't have mattered
this is the fight game you don't know
what the [ __ ] happened michael chandler
charles oliveira yeah look how that
changes what do you know well even conor
mcgregor chad mendes
i mean yeah exactly i was like chad
mendes was crack like kind of like
[ __ ] yeah and he got up and knocked him
out like that that [ __ ] can happen
decisively too yeah no question
so do you did you guys enjoy so this is
the controversial part right where it's
funny because ronda rousey wrote a tweet
about this where
ronda rousey was giving conor mcgregor
props for promoting his next fight even
when his
leg was shattered yeah certain people
such as like matt sarah believed that he
went too far so if you guys didn't see
this part of the fight
um very entertaining a little
controversial because the first thing
that he does
when dustin party gets on the mic or
whatever or when he gets on the mic
he starts yelling obscenities at dustin
poirier's wife
yeah right start saying like hey baby
i'll see you at the wind
uh you slid into my tm that's crazy you
know what i heard i was like
[ __ ] nuts yeah he goes i see you in
my [ __ ] dms your wife's a hoe
i was like bro and it's funny because
his leg is shattered dustin has to just
walk over and crack you
the fact that his [ __ ] is shattered and
he's still talking [ __ ] that's what's
crazy that
was crazy to me yeah it's insane he
knows his [ __ ] is broken
and the fact that he's still in the
moment is kind of crazy right it is
crazy
it's insane so like we could speculate
here all we want to be like oh yeah he
was trying to sell the fight
i don't think that's what he was doing
but it also could be the fact that like
we don't really know why he's saying all
this [ __ ] right
could it be in his mind he's like i
gotta sell this fight it could be
but also what's more likely right more
likely is him being just being
really frustrated with the loss yeah
frustrated with the outcome of all this
[ __ ] because think about
what was on the stake here you know
right right right and he's just like
[ __ ] grasping at anything he can
he just wants to fight even in the press
conference right like he was
saying he it wasn't conor's best work
yeah like we're used to him being
to me it seemed kind of forced and
that's why i think like i don't think he
wants to be this guy anymore
yeah but he feels like he has to in some
sort of way
so he says this [ __ ] like your wife's
your husband
or some [ __ ] and it's like thanks like
even dustin poyne was like yo
you used to be good at this bro like
what the [ __ ] happened yeah you said
that so which is
yeah dustin poyo was hey he was he was
dropping bars this whole fight
but like it was just weird to see him do
all the [ __ ] and he just seems like a
desperate guy
yeah because he knows his like his
legacy his relevance is kind of slipping
from him a little bit
you know but who [ __ ] knows i think
it's more that i think it's more like
that he i feel like he thinks his
prime's kind of slipping
yeah and it's his reaction to that yeah
more than
especially when it's so fresh it just
happened but i don't think like
at the end i don't think he was thinking
like let me market this yeah yeah yeah
leg is snapped yeah yeah i think it was
just pure like frustration anger like
[ __ ]
this you gotta look at it like this
right there's only now two
people in the ufc that's been able to
damage his [ __ ] legacy
habib habib wouldn't give him his fight
back dustin now has the cards
does can say i beat your ass [ __ ]
twice you'll never fight me again
that's gonna eat at conor's soul for the
rest of his life
habib and dustin dominated you he has to
live with that [ __ ] because at the end
of the day he's a [ __ ] fighter
you know he said he said it the best he
goes i'm not a [ __ ] celebrity
i crack people's skulls and i [ __ ]
sound
so good yeah so that's a good line i
take my check and i [ __ ] bounce
see but i think the only way for conor
to get some clown back
is he has to work his way back up and i
feel like when conor was at his best
was when he was active he was fighting
multiple times a year yeah he was
fighting four times a year and he was
fighting everybody he was working his
way up
and the past few losses that he's had is
against
top tier contenders we're talking habib
who
if you lose to habib it's almost not
he's so good
all the best guys in their prime easy he
beat him you know like and without
any like competition at all so for a guy
like connor for him to even and even for
me too
like as a fight fan i don't want to see
the fight
if dustin beats charles oliveira which i
think he will
i don't want to see him rematch conor
automatically he needs another fight i
need to see
connor work his way back up the division
yes
but like he needs to work his way back
up the division to make sure that
he's still not he's he's still not this
crazy guy that people think he is like
we need to see that he's
actually willing to fight and and be in
the gym and be a gym rat i feel like
that's the only thing that he's been
missing from his whole career recently
because he has so much going on
he needs to be in the gym he needs to be
fighting because
even with him looking as well as he did
recently
we still feel like something's off a
little bit like he's not as sharp a
little bit he's not
maybe he might be the instincts or not a
strong one have you ever seen somebody
thrive at
something when they have 18 other things
going on in their life yeah exactly
ever multi-million dollar companies and
[ __ ] you know it doesn't he
it's not that he doesn't have it he
doesn't have the time or he doesn't
he doesn't care enough like he did
before that dude was on welfare checks
before man
like his wife was supporting him he had
like this [ __ ]
fire in him that he needed to that he
needed to fix it just
it's different now you know and it's
hard for him to admit it say like
you know what my life is different now
and i don't have the same [ __ ] flame
yep
especially in combat sports right even
in boxing you don't see
guys that do [ __ ] outside of the sport
and then come back and back and forth
and you never see them be
so successful in the sport after they do
that [ __ ] right
but especially in mma the variables that
happen
there are so many [ __ ] variables so
many things can happen and if you're not
on your [ __ ] game and if you're not
training muay thai if you're not doing
your boxing you're not doing your
wrestling you're not doing jiu jitsu all
that alone
is like a [ __ ] nightmare to to
navigate through right
so for a guy like conor if he's not in
the gym putting that work in
there's no way you could be successful
against a guy like dustin
who's been fighting everybody in the
past like five years smash
yo if you if you look at people
people [ __ ] sleep on dustin so much
yeah look at his
[ __ ] resume look at the people he has
slept
and beaten the [ __ ] out of right minus
habib yeah
everybody except habib yeah eddie
alvarez yeah
justin gaichy [ __ ] insane dude people
forget like what do you what what does
this man need to do to be like yo
respect me
yeah right exactly when i was watching
him like after the fight i was like yo
this is the he's to my opinion he's the
best lightweight
in the world yeah i mean it's a guy from
louisiana right everyone is like oh man
it's like you know all these guys
nigerian fighters like
izzy and kamaru and then you have
[ __ ] you know all these brazilian
champions but then this guy from
louisiana
is the best lightweight in the world
right now
in my opinion and also in a sport that's
just dominated by
russians and you know nigerians and
everybody from all across the world
yeah and it's from a guy from louisiana
very humble beginnings
dustin's for sure i think that he's the
uncrowned champ like you said earlier
he's he's a beast
dude there's a cool ass documentary
about him like the fightville
yeah have you seen that one of the first
ones i've ever seen i've seen that a
long time ago
it was like it's basically dustin's uh
path to get to the ufc over your sucking
dick by a burning garbage can
yeah this is how i came up with my idea
for my hot sauce
sucker dick yeah that dick was spicy he
used to be a ups or a fedex driver
and like it shows like his whole like he
was fighting in barnes and [ __ ] and he
was still
uh training with was that guy timid tim
crater or tim yeah tim crater tim crater
in louisiana and like it's dope as [ __ ]
like especially for like if you watch it
now because i watched it back then and i
thought it was dope i was like i like
this guy
but now seeing like how he is and you
watch that it's like dude humble
beginnings to the max like he's been in
and he's been a guy forever you want to
see he's so likable
yeah yeah he's very like i'm a huge
connor fan but i'm also a huge dustin
fan like you you can't
come both too you can't hear him talking
to me like this guy sucks he's saying
all the right stuff
he's cool and he's genuine you know he's
a very nice real [ __ ]
he's legit in his prime because he keeps
getting better and better every fight
yup his left is [ __ ] fast dude yeah
when in the [ __ ] did he get that piston
when out of nowhere because he cracked
conor in the fight with it and i didn't
see it coming i was like yo what the
[ __ ] where did that come from
he landed a nice uppercut too yeah there
was like the cross and then he landed on
an uppercut and then that's what
initiated
i think went in for the clinch yeah
rocked him a little bit
yeah he did he stunned him for sure max
holloway was talking about it and he was
saying like
he has a really weird like timing
and that's why he was like i'd see the
punch come but it would just come hella
slow and i wasn't expecting that
and it would hit me over and over and
over again so he's this guy dustin and
he figures out
how like his style right because you
tell most people most boxers are like
everybody has their own unique kind of
striking ability and that's
pretty much dustin's everything is kind
of weird like it's like looping shots
but
it seems like on tv it doesn't seem like
it's going too fast
or like it's anything connecting
impressive but it's landing every single
time like he
has volume and he can hit you over and
over again
and when you watch him in that fight
with dan hooker that fight was [ __ ]
amazing no and you just hear the shots
being landed like crack
crack crack it was like one of the most
violent like fights you've ever seen you
know
if i was so wild it didn't go to the
distance did it did it didn't he stop oh
you didn't
go distance because they were both just
killing each other he's like yeah
if you've never watched fighting before
if you want to see a man
get punched in the face 700 times you
can watch
the moutino and sean o'malley fight he
landed
at a 80 percent rate for that will smith
movie about concussions and cte
could have just been made about that
fight alone 100
here's the weird thing about this right
and i say this
everybody just go online find a clip of
this [ __ ] and watch this
fight you are going to see a d you're
going to see levels to this [ __ ] right
first of all will sean o'malley exactly
if i want to touch you i'll touch you
whenever the [ __ ] i want
it's literally this and dude i mean
moutinho had a great plan
block every punch with my face yeah i
like every single [ __ ] like
i loved it he put his hands up but the
gloves were still going through the
garden yeah
but every punch that [ __ ] sean
o'malley through landed on his face i
don't think he missed it
he's moving backwards dude i like sean
o'malley is nice
really good he hit him with like seven
head kicks yeah how
his movement was so and like the way he
would escape like uh the
i forgot that what's his name jordina
what moutinho justin
the way he would like be crowding him on
the cage sean o'malley would like fake
movement this way and then
weave out the other way like just boom
boom and just like
he wanted to do it were amazing dude his
footwork is so good
that's that's just slick as [ __ ]
it brought up a couple of questions too
though it's like is moutinho that tough
or does shawn o'malley not hit as hard
as other people in the division
i think that kid is just that i think
that guy's just that tough because sean
o'malley is but all those people for
sure people pressing him so he's moving
backwards
that's right he doesn't get to sit down
on the shots and throw he needs to
o'malley dropped him that's right like
he did drop him i thought he was like
around he dropped down yeah hard
actually in the la before herb dean
stopped it
he planted and he he was cracking him
dude i was like
there's the power shots yeah you know
but everybody was giving her dean some
[ __ ] about stopping the fight 30 seconds
before
and they're like well you should have
stopped in the first round no that's not
how it works
right right somebody gets cracked a lot
in the first round and by the way
people gave a lot of [ __ ] to the rest
for not stopping the calvin kater fight
and i think her dean had that fight too
yeah they were giving him [ __ ] about not
stopping the calvin kater fight so what
the [ __ ] do you want yeah yeah right
there's 30 seconds left in the fight
moutinho can get hit the way he was
getting hit another 40 times well he
saved himself
yeah and not just that but you like you
said that's when sean o'malley planted
and i think arab dean could tell the
difference like it's done like he's not
just moving back now it's like it was
turning
like he planted and was landing power
power shots now it was like
this it was actually right like he
doesn't have to take those
unnecessary super fat power shots but
also though when you get when you take
that
type of damage you only get one fight
like that yeah oh yeah you're changed
completely
i'm like tony ferguson wasn't the same
after he fought justin gates nope
junior dos santos after he fought cain
velasquez not the same
right then you look i'm worried about
calvin kater cause he's such a young
talent this podcast is brought to you by
raycon earbuds my friends listen to me
right now like you're listening to me on
this podcast if you are walking around
with wired earbuds what the
hecks are you doing you need something
lightweight
you need something without wires you
need something affordable but with
premium sound and quality and that's
raycon earbuds there's a lot of other
competitors out there that are selling
you something out there
that is way too expensive and they are
trying to jip you recon is not that
you know what the best thing about them
too is they have a 24 hour battery life
yes i can't tell you how many wireless
earbuds that i have
bought that die after a few hours and it
sucks especially when i'm on a plane and
i have to charge
my earbuds after they die in a mere
matter of moments
not with my raikon earbuds listening
pleasure for everybody all the time
well listen up raycon's offering 15 off
all their products for my listeners and
here's what you got to do to get it
go to buy recon dot com brain there
you'll get 15
off your entire recon order and it's
such a good deal
you'll want to grab a pair and a spare
that's
15 off at byraycon.com brain that's
by raycon dot com slash brain who's so
good
i don't know if he's going to be the
same but to to an example on the on the
opposite side brian ortega versus max
holloway
yeah that's true good that's true but he
took the time off though he took the
time off
and i think hopefully calvin cater takes
that time off right yeah but a guy like
chris moutinho
like you said there's levels to this
game and
a lot of people were kind of like giving
[ __ ] to sean o'malley like oh he should
have finished him but
in reality it's like he's unranked close
this kid
clinic and he just showed what time it
is you know and
i don't i don't understand that
criticism at all it's like bro that dude
is just
tough as [ __ ] yeah like that's not
anything a knock on shout out the weird
thing is too
the people were also saying too is like
dude justin
moutinho like his stock is up that guy's
a warrior i was like bro
i cool you took a lot of great hits
what else yeah yeah i took nothing away
from the fight all i know is that you in
this division
you ain't gonna make it yeah well the
thing is is he did fight like sean
o'malley is very slick though yeah you
know if he fights somebody that like
doesn't have no one moves like sean
o'malley so maybe and he was kind of
getting close sometimes yeah
i mean he cracked him he got a little
shiner from a good little looping a
little bit but but like if you fight
somebody that's a little more planted or
something but he landed 250 strikes to
his
face yeah 250 strikes in another
three-round fight that's crazy that's
insane
i'll tell you this though like let's say
like boutino right
he fights somebody like jose aldo he's
not going to come out alive
he's going to wake up in another
dimension wearing a [ __ ] dress
thinking that he works at a [ __ ] seas
candy
he's going to have a career change dude
yeah yeah he's not going to know what
the [ __ ] happened to him what a nice
lifestyle change though huh yeah
punch in the face you're like i work
with his candidates this candy's nice i
like to work there it'd be cool yeah
good chocolate [ __ ] all those
employees
every single green haired babies people
were just people just
hyped up like like dude this guy's a
warrior cool
but still nobody wants to see somebody
get hit in the face 300 times yeah
because
at a certain point in time there's a
there's a reason why this kid wasn't in
the league before
unfortunately like no i don't want to be
the guy that has to say it but
he wasn't ufc caliber and obviously he
fought
a a big superstar in the bantamweight
division
but like you just don't want to see
fights like that
because who has to pay for at the end of
the day
it's chris montino yeah he's gonna pay
for it with his brain damage
he doesn't you know he might get paid
75k which is great
but what's it worth at the end of the
day these are people's lives either our
brains is our families like this [ __ ] is
dark bro like the fight game always wins
right yeah
you saw the conor fight like yeah it's
all lavish and we've seen him on the
highest of highs like also
one of the most fun like rides to follow
was conor mcgregor's career like
but then you look at it with all the
money in the world and all that
look what happened to him right he just
stuck around he shouldn't get he should
have just [ __ ]
showed up but it's like a problem with
fighters right it's like yeah
that becomes their identity and that's
what they're known for
and you see it all the time nate
marquardt
he just signed to the lfa why the [ __ ]
are you fighting again bro you don't
wait it's a fight now
yeah recently a couple months like we
fought in like [ __ ] 10 years
you are a legend in the sport you're a
pioneer in the sport you do not need to
be fighting
maybe he feels like he needs to which is
fine who gives a [ __ ] like that's
whatever he wants to do is his
prerogative right
but at the end of the day as a fan i'm
like bro i don't want to see you fight
and elephant
they don't got [ __ ] in there either
yeah they got [ __ ] kids bro like they
got guys who are trying
to make a name off of you they they're
the young guys that want to make in the
sport like
came from [ __ ] lfa dude well like
like habib
right you hear him talk everyone's like
you need to come back and he goes i'm
good
yeah i've done everything i need to do
in the sport
yeah i've trained the harness i put
everything i need to to
be successful because he's smart and he
knows
that if i come back you know whether he
he knows he doesn't want that anymore
and if that's what it is you have to
walk away from the sport yeah right
people
feel unforgiving yo yeah they also
misconstrue his legacy because like oh
he only had x amount of fights
in the u.s is the goat 13-0 this gets
the best guys this is what they're
[ __ ] up with too it's like they're
like oh well they
other people on that roster have fought
more people right it's like that is a
sorry argument
because within his 13 wins within the
ufc and maybe the people
that you knew were like four or five
people but they were in the top and in
their prime
and he didn't just beat them he
embarrassed them dominated
dominated you have to go back and watch
these fights
go back to poirier who we so much love
and see
how terribly he dismantled him yeah
poor yet yeah right he is arguably the
best in that division right now made him
look
average exactly oh we just [ __ ] okay
okay fight and the fight that
that um put habib on the map as far as
like a media wise was the michael
johnson fight yeah
right michael johnson the fight before
that knocked out dustin poirier
yep oh yeah that's right knocked him out
uh habib was supposed to fight eddie
alvarez for the title
he signed the contract right this is the
madison square garden card
um in in new york right
connor took khabib's place conor's a
bigger star
they put him against eddie alvarez and
they fight and habib goes okay
but give me a fight i want to fight
somebody bites michael johnson
you fight him almost gets slept too yeah
and and honestly too like he beats the
[ __ ] out of him and he's talking to him
while he's beating his [ __ ] ass and
he goes yo
like you know i you know i deserve the
title shot like i must fight for the
belt brother like you
you as he's beating the [ __ ] out of him
and he's talking to daniel white he's
like dana
in between rounds like you want to talk
a little bit and then it's like what do
you want to talk about
he was like i must fight for taito you
understand this like you keep hiding
your chicken
like it's just a different mindset with
these guys at the at
like nobody is like habib right yeah
right people want to compare jon jones
in my opinion
no no me neither habib has never
bled in the octagon
i think he lost maybe one or two rounds
in the history and that's because he was
[ __ ] around yeah and he's only been
hit
a few times yeah he's barely been hit he
took all the best knockout punchers he
took all their shots and was like what's
up
what's up also too yeah he also makes
people who don't like grappling like
grappling yeah yeah that's true he gets
he's made me
busy dude like well because even on the
same card there was gilbert burns and
thompson right gilbert burns got a lot
of [ __ ]
because he didn't do much he just laid
and prayed
and then he sucked thompson the back of
the head ten times yeah yeah
at the end of his neck bro
why'd you hit him in the back of the
head so much man it was a little stupid
it's like you didn't have to do all that
special man and it's so hard like even
for gilbert burns like
when you get a guy like wonder boy who's
just so scrappy and he's so good at
getting up to his feet
like if you're holding somebody down if
you're not using
all of your mic to hold somebody down
and when the moment you try to give an
opening to try to land strikes or try to
go for submission
you're giving that person an opportunity
to get up to their feet and you don't
want to do that with a guy like
wonderboy
but you see how bieb do this everybody
knows what he's going to do
he's going to take you down hold you
down and
guys are training their whole training
camps to stop
every single move that he does and it's
it's a very systematic thing like you
could watch
it you could study it you could do it
but nobody does it like habib
and he still can't do [ __ ] about it yeah
he's
active he's hunting for some missions
and he's bullying people on the ground
and they have been preparing their whole
fight camp to do
to stop this and they can't even find
any success
it is insane how he's like he's just
beyond everybody else in the division
aka too what i really like about them
and that what we keep on seeing too
they're utilizing uh the single leg
takedown versus the double now yeah
they're they're literally using that
cage to their advantage yep
and every time that we've seen in the
history of the ufc and i've heard it so
many times
is lock those arms around both legs
double leg and take them down
dc before [ __ ] habib single leg
takedowns
right it's the most vulnerable thing and
he takes them to take them to the ground
they have transitions yeah like if you
don't get the the dump right away
switch the double leg oh you don't get
that clear the leg go to the back like
they have systems off of this yeah dc
was commentating on gilbert burns
uh thompson fight and there was a
situation where this exact thing happens
where gilbert burns has thompson against
the cage thompson's like spread his legs
or whatever
and dc's explaining exactly what he's
like no he's never going to get it he
has to switch to the single
he kind of he's like it's just a waste
of energy and eventually gilbert burns
does he's like see
right there that's exactly what it was
but like he literally talks right
through that thing and you know that's
exactly
when you watch your fights they do when
you see dc like coach like wrestling and
do you see like he just has such a good
understanding of these positions
and then fighting this weekend is going
to be islam right
who knows how biebs like they grew up
training together since they were like
five years old yo and he's also a
[ __ ] man
so it's like he's the second coming of
habib we're going to see if he lives up
to this expectation
that habib has left on the division and
he's going through the same woes nobody
wants to fight
nobody wants a fight that he would he's
the number nine guy ranked in the world
no he can't get a fight of anybody above
him he has to fight the number 14 guy
what does he have to to earn by fighting
the number 14 guy right but he's like
[ __ ] it i just want to fight bro like
please somebody give me a fight
but nobody wants to fight this dude
because he's that like the what he did
to drew dober in the last fight which is
crazy
that was crazy dover is is a [ __ ]
he's
he's a stud bro yeah he's a beast and he
made him look like he didn't like he's
never done jesus in his life
and it's not because drew dober's whack
or anything like that it just shows how
good
islam is and he's been training with the
best of all time
for his whole life and the it's not just
the skills it's the mentality
it's everything that comes along with
that like just that hard work mentality
and those guys embody that
i was watching a clip of um them just
training at aka and you know they always
show the goofy stuff yeah
but it was them not even being goofy
they're like are you tired
[ __ ] go home like that's what it is
go home and they're like what are you
going to do when you go home and he goes
do what you normally go cry
bro my feelings were being hurt you're
like god damn you talking to me i was
like
oh my god but these are fighters and
literally it's like if you're not hungry
enough
get the [ __ ] out of my gym yeah they
don't give a [ __ ] over there dude yeah
we only want warriors and we want people
who are ready to [ __ ] work and then
but it translates like their mentality
is so beyond
like the fact that habib fought justin
gaichi not only is [ __ ]
hero and his everything passing away the
guy that
got him into the sport that did
everything with him not only the biggest
hair of him
dying from covid plus he had mumps
oh my god that was the [ __ ] is mumps bro
like that's some old-timey [ __ ] yeah
that's like a [ __ ] 16th century
disease
yeah it is and then he [ __ ] wrestled
it out of his body he had a bubonic
plague yeah maybe he had a broken foot
going into the fight
and then justin gaichi is kicking the
[ __ ] out of his legs
and even though b was like oh yeah that
was the hardest kicks i've ever felt but
you watched that fight
didn't seem like it it didn't seem like
it was like he sprinted
at him the whole time
i had the biggest lesson that today
because i was training with savant and
then he was literally
we were going through a drill where we
every any single way you can invade a
jab
right block slip
pull back under close the distance right
yeah he goes
cool but your face looks like you're
scared of [ __ ]
flicking these jabs a little fast at me
you know that's how
you know i was like oh i didn't know but
literally my face was like this oh [ __ ]
you know but he's like poker face he's
like wait you're in a [ __ ] fight
because he knows i'm not gonna fight but
he wants me to train like i'm fighting
right he goes poker face even if you're
[ __ ] scared that this jab's going to
come they can't
know that yeah make sure that your poker
face is strong but i didn't know i was
like this
all grinded down and [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
roasting me it was
like damn [ __ ] my feelings get hurt i'm
dying laughing
that was [ __ ] funny man yeah he'll
put it on you bro he'll
make sure you get that real work he's
definitely because he's old school with
it bro he don't give up he don't [ __ ]
around
yeah [ __ ] an exhausting exhausting
session
he makes you train for an hour but in
reality it's like two hours
it's it's a thousand hours dude it was
the most exhausting [ __ ] ever bro
she threw it huh in the morning i was
[ __ ] uh 219 pounds
and then when we were done training i
was 214 wow that's how much i sweated
i don't even lose that much weight in
the sauna dude yeah i he took he
my spirit left that was the weight of my
spirit it was gone
all that sweat gone yeah and that's what
it was just hard and
every time i'm like [ __ ] yakking and
this fool is like this [ __ ]
speaking in tongues
did you throw up i almost did oh [ __ ]
because it was weird because training
though
yeah it is that's necessary it was all
footwork right and just moving around
that small ring for [ __ ] three
minutes straight
just lateral movement constantly
circling circling circling going in
entries and then he brought the paddles
out he goes now we're going to do this
with
strikes it made me want to throw up just
throwing and moving
yeah because it was already tiring
enough just moving as it is and he goes
now
you're gonna you have to know when
you're gonna plant you have to know
every time you [ __ ] throw that cross
or that jab or whatever your left foot
you're either rolling or you're pivoting
out yeah i want that at all times
people think boxing and real fighting is
like oh just throwing punches
but it's that is not even you're not
even scratching the surface
yeah i don't know without proper
footwork and your ability to navigate
this open space you being able to throw
punches
doesn't matter it doesn't mean [ __ ]
doesn't mean i feel like footwork is way
more important breathing
everything yeah if you can't put
yourself in a position to strike or to
land your big [ __ ]
your big bombs it doesn't matter yeah it
does not or get out of the way
exactly i mean you're gonna get knocked
the [ __ ] out if you don't know how to
move out of the way
you know what i mean or don't don't
understand dis distance management or
whatever but
it's just really hard it's it's so
[ __ ] hard like i didn't realize how
hard boxing was right
because like i feel like with with muay
thai you have so many weapons to parry
block move out the way
clinch grab boxing there's totally
different game there's no there's none
of that
it's it's it's movement closing the
distance
and then getting out of this corner
that's really what it is and then you
watch a guy like lomachenko right oh my
god
and you're like this machine is un
unfucking believable
dude you want to talk about [ __ ]
asian hate he beat the [ __ ] out of that
japanese city
who was that guy poor guy man he's like
he's a [ __ ] really good boxer he
he punches his [ __ ] head like a pez
dispenser right i know yeah
yeah he was big why isn't loma fighting
uh tio female lopez i think he's
trying to set it up they gotta get they
gotta make the house he didn't want to
have
um a rematch clause uh loma oh he
definitely this is a
this is from teo fema's camp yeah and
then so teo fema won he was like nah
[ __ ] that
[ __ ] that rematch you don't want to have
a rematch on me i'm not gonna have a
rematch with you because
his dad wants it though because his dad
wants to cement his son's legacy but
also
in that fight there's a lot of questions
that happen like
yeah good right tino female is a beast
like i don't want to take anything away
from them but loma was turning on
towards the end i don't know why he
didn't do anything in the first seven
rounds he had a torn shoulder exactly
like
right after the fight he got another
shoulder surgery but it was kind of
weird i was like
what's happening like it took him away
it took him a while though it seemed
like he
turned on like round seven running but
when he did it
it was like okay and now he's like okay
it's starting to happen female was still
hanging in there
like it wasn't like it was just a
shutout but yeah it was lomo started
punches
move it makes what savant's saying make
more sense right
context everything it's it's defense
with offense that's really what it is
it's not offense with defense yeah
because once you have that ability to
move
and and to defend properly it opens up a
whole nother side of
offense that's just so much easier to
land like yeah i just never knew
how important it was like i knew but you
don't know until you're trying it
yourself yeah
right just like talk speaking of just
defense in general right like you watch
tai toivasa obviously there it was a it
was a chaotic fight
yeah but him missing and him uh greg
hardy throwing that big shot
and putting him out of position cost him
the fight
cost him the fight yeah you know and and
he just threw himself into
a short hook bank and just knocked the
[ __ ] out blew up his [ __ ] eye
if you guys don't know tai tui vasa is
his huge ass samoan [ __ ] yeah
heavyweight in the ufc
yeah i was having a kind of a small uh
rough stint in the ufc he started to
take a break
start to work on something he never
utilized which is with his kicks
low kicks amazing biggest [ __ ] thighs
are dude and he was
spinning [ __ ] greg hardy around yeah
he wasn't expecting that
yeah he was like yo what the [ __ ] and
greg hardy who
is a former professional football player
huge as [ __ ]
super long reach and he made tyto ivasa
actually look kind of small
he did in the beginning of the fight
greg hardy looks at tai tui vasa and he
points at the middle
and the first thing i thought was you
aren't doing that to the wrong person
yeah you don't do it to somebody name
[ __ ] bam bam
you gotta out point this [ __ ]
bro yeah yeah and he just
like he was like i'm ready to [ __ ]
throw down and greg and greg hardy has a
great jab
but literally greg hardy connected
either with with a hard cross
and then he you know uh tai tui vasa had
a bit of noodle legs
but he recomposed himself so he's
smiling yeah
planted himself literally hook plant
another hook dead probably broke his
orbital that makes me so happy to watch
because nobody likes greg hardy yeah so
what's up with him he's like got some
beat up a woman oh that's what it was
that's what it was apparently it's like
not confirmed but but it's like uh
yeah he definitely did it he got a
travel tattoo unfinished by the way he
has an unfinished tribal tattoo
hey man finish that tribal tattoo what
are you doing tied to avasta too
he's crazy duffel has a chip on his
shoulder he was like he pointed he was
like
he pointed in the [ __ ] middle of the
of the [ __ ] cage he's like
from avengers yeah he [ __ ] pointed to
the floor uh
and i had to punch him in the face i had
to [ __ ] him up he's like on the left
what do you want to do
with me dog this full he did like seven
chewies i know on the way out on the way
in
so everywhere in vegas this guy's on a
social media just doing shoes that
everybody is poor [ __ ]
gusting he definitely has covered now he
has to do it he's the cure bro he got
the answer bodies you don't need that
[ __ ]
somebody poured uh dustin's hot sauce in
it oh yeah yeah yeah
this fool is like oh the thing he goes
was that [ __ ] pourier's hot sauce
disgusting i'm like damn bro he's
destroying his business right now bro
he's like it was gross as [ __ ] i
actually had the hot sauce it's not bad
really
it's not spicy oh it just it tastes
pretty good though what does it taste
compared to
i say a non-spicy less slimy tapatio
oh yeah but it's like a louisiana hot
sauce with a little more viscosity ooh
i do like louisiana like the the rooster
one i don't know what the [ __ ] it's
called
and crystal is bomb too yeah it's a
little uh less vinegary than that it's
like a mix
between everything but it tastes really
good though i think it tastes [ __ ]
great
i want to try that yeah sold out
everywhere we gotta do shoeies
have you done a shoei oh [ __ ] alex
did that chewy go
you know gilbert used to play rugby
right really gilbert's party
[ __ ] out of here dude um he played in
like chicago or something
and they made him do a shoei and he goes
it was i i gagged thinking about it to
this day
he played rugby is one of the roughest
[ __ ] sports football was striking
yeah yeah it's crazy without pads
without the protection people tear their
shoulders ankles
all the time in there that's why you got
a biggest [ __ ] in the world
yeah we got a big old fat ass for you do
you do it
for that booty hormones got secrets dude
you [ __ ]
did [ __ ] rugby he did he he's a fast
bro we were all we
went to vegas this past weekend with him
this guy bro
he charms the pants off everybody yeah
these [ __ ] were just giving us
free [ __ ] wherever we went people were
just like
just because he's just talking to him
and he's just like you know schmoozing
he's not even schmoozing it's just
it's genuine like he really wants to
like oh like he's asking questions about
people
people they just want to be a part of
gills they just want to be a part of it
they just want to hang out with the
[ __ ] guys [ __ ] nipples had that
[ __ ] black and white swirl he's
hidden
and that's what it is
i put down like getting [ __ ]
hypocrites
you were in vegas that's right huh yeah
it was cool look at this guy
dude we went to berk house and we went
to geo's house we had a
good old time with them hanging out with
tyka house was
[ __ ] so big their house is
the living room looks like the biggest
thing i've ever seen it's a hotel lobby
bro it's like an art gallery
actually there um we stayed at the red
rock their living room is bigger than
the red rocks lobby then the casino yeah
and the ceilings are higher at a [ __ ]
bart's house it's ridiculous if you want
to feel like a piece of [ __ ] just stay
at their house for a couple days yeah
okay i believe it i've just seen the
videos and i was like jesus christ this
fool lives in a [ __ ] museum or what
yeah
god damn bro we forgot to talk about
[ __ ] ryan hall getting it
just tearing people's knees out starts
[ __ ] around for a full round
doing the weird i've never seen somebody
go for a takedown or like an ankle pick
that way
it's like opposite opposite hand of the
ankle he's grabbing
and reversing the grip this way yeah
which i feel what he was trying to do
was get a submission off of that
takedown to promote
this new move that he created and he
kept doing it over
and over and over i'm like ryan hall
what are you doing
yeah uh elio i think his name ilya
tapurio
who is the [ __ ] beast he looks like
gaston yup
this is yeah he looks exactly like him
just more tattoos
but like this just shows and mma if you
are too one-dimensional oh yeah you do
not have a
see another path to victory
you are going to get smashed out as good
as ryan hall is if ryan hall
got uh to puria to the ground he
probably would have subbed him right
that's just
how good of a submission artist he is
but with all the tools
that tapuria has and he just was playing
smart he knew exactly what to do
it's just really hard to to like what he
did what ryan hall did to bj penn
you're not going to see that very often
no and that's also bj pen like an older
bj
and it's like we know like we know
that's what he's going to do
right he is trying to fish for that
inverted immunity role
which is very hard to do sure and
against a guy
who is also a bjj black belt yeah right
who is a greco-roman specialist like
interpreter he's a [ __ ] animal
and he could strike very well dude it
just
it sucks to see because you want to see
ryan hall and after he had such a long
layoff
you want to see him do well you want to
see him fight because he's a jiu jitsu
legend
but it's just hard to think that he's
going to have more success if he doesn't
change anything up
it was just it was it was so interesting
just watching him because
the hardest thing that he was doing i
think with ryan hall is that he's very
good off his back right
so he's always his biggest advantage is
that
is he needs to roll so as long as he
could roll he's going to
mitigate a lot of this offense well
guess what this [ __ ]
put him literally locked up his body
couldn't roll
get on his shoulder crack boom crack
crack side control locked him up he
tried to roll he goes
i'm stuck yeah beat the living breaks
off of him
did you listen to the uh john donahue
podcast with joe rogan
listen to it the last one not the latest
he talks about like three main
he's a [ __ ] animal yeah he's just
like a wizard but he
breaks it down three main weaknesses of
jiu jitsu he's like the first one is
leglocks he's like that's what i've been
like devoting he's devoting his career
to like tackling these three main issues
in jiu jitsu uh leglocks i think the
second one was takedowns
right getting somebody that i think it
was taking down getting getting
uh of somebody to the ground and then
the third one was actually holding them
down he's like these are three like
fatal flaws in jiu jitsu that we
need to address like as a community that
we we aren't you know he's like
people are talking about learning uh
wrestling as a remedy he's like but i
don't buy into that he's like
we need to figure out a way in jiu jitsu
how to do it and when he when i was
watching ryan hall i was like thinking
about all the
[ __ ] he was saying and i was like it's
so true yeah like you just use a [ __ ]
but it's like if you can't take a
[ __ ] down and hold them down and
do your thing it's like then jujitsu is
there's no point like
what are you gonna do you know and you
think about that and then you look at
habib
right he has solved all those problems
yeah
and he's done it to the master level
that no one else we've seen in the sport
was able to do
but he was struck but khabib is strong
wrestling like i mean his jits is strong
but it's not just like wrestling but
it's not just the wrestling it's
overall grappling because everything
that he does is a setup it's
it's it's like with straight jiu jitsu
guys like
[ __ ] is pretty much jiu jitsu
and you know uh wrestling combined into
one thing
that's why you see these guys that are
[ __ ] players they
they do very well at a high level and
they're also doing
uh like striking too but habiba has a
system
and he's holding people down he's
keeping their arms trapped
and he's also just sucking [ __ ]
out so but when it comes to just
straight jiu jitsu it's not going to be
that's what the the flaws because he was
talking about the leg locks right
when you guys are like a ryan hall's
going for leg locks both of his arms are
occupied on one leg
and then if you are not isolating
properly
the upper part of the person's body that
is defending the leg lock
they're going to punch you in the
[ __ ] face yeah right if you don't
snap that [ __ ] and you don't have the
proper leverage and
it's a little too slippery and you can't
get that you are
risking yourself to get knocked the [ __ ]
out and that's exactly right everybody
like before they even watch the ufc
should know what it feels like to have
somebody on top of you holding you down
it's the most helpless feeling on earth
oh yeah because everybody talks about
solutions as if it's hyper simplistic
right they're like
dude dustin just get up all right yeah
people think he's not
trying yeah pistol is [ __ ] grappling
the [ __ ] out of him dude
if he gets up in the wrong way in the
slightest it's oh yeah
he's opening himself up to another set
of problems
whether he's getting punched in the face
getting slammed on his head or just
giving a position where this guy is
going to choke him the [ __ ] out yeah
it's really hard to defend that but dude
going back to john danner he's a [ __ ]
genius
yeah he really is bro he's a serial
killer he might be he's definitely a
serial killer that found jujitsu yeah
and then he chose not to kill anymore
yeah yeah he's like a yoda like a
legitimate
yeah he was he was a professor he only
wears rash guards all the time
in case some [ __ ] goes down there's
people talking about like there was
weddings like
from the guys from the gym got married
and he would be there in a rash guard
at the wedding [ __ ] that same energy
bro
that's the most samurai [ __ ] i've ever
heard in my life like he only wears rice
like john danaher like be outside and
he's wearing his rash guard and somebody
approaches him he goes
i'm always ready for a fight and then
somebody just shoots him in the chest
and then he's going to be fine because
the rash guard is bulletproof i didn't
think about the situation
they just said that it's like you just
who couldn't stop bullets because he's
fascinating you ever hear him talk like
he is really interested listen to the
podcast he can talk about [ __ ]
anything and you're just like i'm in
you think it's just because he has a
british accent i think he's from new
zealand
but he does a lot of that you're a piece
of [ __ ] does he not have a british
accent
he has a new zealand accent he's a
[ __ ] kid what does that sound like
huh
he sounds a little bit like australian
and a little bit like british he's the
guy
what's the cork uh that from the movie
that's that's like that's like that's
new zealand
yeah that's new zealand yeah all white
people look like you [ __ ] reverse
racists
is a very common british name is it is
it
it's you know the loyal family of the
the dead
another common british
what's prince charles what's his last
name bro charles
that's it what's her last name do they
have a last name
they gotta have a last name what is
diana's last name no princess diana
attenborough
shut up no you live on bruh yeah
that's a dude from [ __ ] planet earth
i know meghan markle's last name prince
william prince willie is that buckingham
is her last name buckingham
it was on jk news we were talking about
the body language expert too yeah bro
those guys are like [ __ ]
sounds when they were talking about what
was it it was like how nervous he was
like speaking to his brother yeah he was
like touching his head a lot so it just
it
exudes he was nervous what do you think
about body language experts i think it's
[ __ ]
for the most part sometimes adjusting i
think there's certain things where you
can tell like someone looks dirty
yeah there's big tails but i mean all
that other [ __ ] when they get too
specific you're like shut the [ __ ] up
because i need to see a controlled test
of it right yeah
and there is no it's all subjective yeah
right i'll say this though man this is
absolutely
no disrespect to body language experts
at all but you're [ __ ] stupid
like you just sit there and you go like
well look at him he [ __ ] winked
twice in the 17th century winking twice
meant that you were selling drugs yeah
he's
high right i'm like you are a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you're so dumb be quiet yeah
where'd you come up with this [ __ ] from
yeah
especially when it's too like specific
on things that like is not very obvious
to see
that's when you're like all right you
might be you might be making some [ __ ]
up
because there was the prince andrew the
guy who was hanging out with epstein
he has his very famous interview where
he's like just sweating the whole
[ __ ] time
and he looks like [ __ ] and they're
asking him really hard questions about
like
if he's be out these kids bro you be
[ __ ] kids
and uh they had body language experts on
that that was really good to watch
because you can see
this fool's tie is like all [ __ ] up
and he's just like sweating and he's
like the way he's like dodging these
questions but we don't need a body
language expert to say that because
there's a picture of him with the girl
yeah he's like and he's like he's like
seen chilling like he's like
i don't know her i i don't i don't
remember taking this picture at all like
i have no recollection i i've never seen
this in my life like
you're like get the [ __ ] out of here
like right bro you started with the baby
blue shirt and now it's navy blue
yeah you sweated so much imagine the
girl that's like in that picture and
she's like yo we [ __ ] bro like you
[ __ ] me when i was 16.
imagine how frustrated she is watching
this interview of this guy like
oh no i have no recollection speaking of
lascivious acts we didn't even talk
about this
cosby's out yeah yeah it was like
right yeah i honestly don't understand
how he got out of jail like when i saw
that i was like wait what how
so apparently civilly he's
guilty yeah but criminally he's
not but then why the [ __ ] was he in jail
at all who [ __ ] knows and no it's
like loopholes
not enough evidence but it's like
there's forty
thousand women that are like exactly you
know what the thing is though about that
is that if you got enough money you can
get
[ __ ] anything real so you you get
good enough lawyers to find something
because it's all it's not about who's
right or wrong it's about who can find
the technicality at that point a lot of
witnesses though
bro like 16 and not only witnesses
people that got raped yeah
like participate yeah like and and do
you think he's gonna go back
to doing what he's doing you think the
jig is up you think there's somebody out
there that just
he's gonna start his own podcast dude
he's about to die bro he's so old course
he's like
his eyes are like you know like when
like old dogs or cats like when they're
like that light blue
layer he's got he's got that is that
right you don't know exactly what he's
looking like
i'm like what is is that what that is
yeah i never knew what that was you
think he's gonna come up with a book of
if i did oh like oj yeah
60 women what i raped how i would have
been did it
was one of my biggest influences growing
up wow
canceled david canceled david i had a
huge poster
i had this huge poster of all my like
like comedy sitcom heroes
it was like will smith it was dave
chappelle
i like chappelle you know posters i had
eddie murphy raw
and then i had a big old bill cosby
posted right there too
i loved his not so much as stand-up but
i loved his sitcom his sitcom molded a
lot of like the way i i view things
yeah right it's like anything can be
made fun of it doesn't matter your
family could get roasted your kids could
get roasted
it was actually a really good show my
favorite sitcom of all time
and then literally that news came out
and i was like this photo means
different things now
have you watched it since the show yeah
because i feel like look obviously it's
it's heathcliff huxtable
it's not bill cosby exactly like i feel
like you could watch
like obviously nobody can here condones
what bill cosby did
right obviously i'm speaking for
everybody right
yeah no one's agreeing with me
everyone's just looking at me yeah bro
yeah you don't condone you don't condone
what bill cosby did
you guys all just stared at me like i
was [ __ ] crazy yeah whatever agree
with me
[ __ ] rape rape forgiver over here
dude i'm trying to [ __ ] you know
but you know we could appreciate what
the [ __ ] you did like r kelly i don't
think i don't agree with
this guy here huh huh let me tell you
something
bro i haven't listened to an r kelly
song
[ __ ] lion bro when i walked in the
house ignition was playing
and merrill was dancing to her brother
you're lying bro
i don't even know who r kelly is who is
he who is he i have no idea
he's a world famous rapist that's right
this guy i know
i'm trying to be rude but hey pretty
good feeling you it's hard
if that's just just playing it's hard
not to lie and you like
it because it takes you a second to like
update like upload the like oh yeah he's
a rapist
so like before that like five second
period or whatever you're for five
seconds you're like
oh you're off you can appreciate his art
but he'll never listen to an r kelly
song ever again
all right we'll see everyone okay did
you get your shots
have you seen that video which one did
you get your shots
would you like to come home with me to
america that was kind of a bad thing
they got the [ __ ] african
uh background singers
that [ __ ] was a barrier bro did you get
your shots
do you have your passport yeah would you
like to come
home with rob to america
and the song ends with if you're 13
you're still
too old that's what it is this
[ __ ] dude this is my
life in that [ __ ] game oh my god they
gotta kill our kelly brother they gotta
they gotta murder him
is he is he free what's what's the
status is he's in jail
yeah i remember like this is probably
over a year ago but he like got [ __ ]
up in jail or something
you gotta murder these people dogs i
heard bill cosby had a pudding put
jello putting thrown in him in the first
day of jail that's hillary the funniest
thing i've ever heard absolutely
that is funny yeah it just landed on his
head and he still eats
[ __ ] a little [ __ ] t-bone in
prison was like this joke gonna hit
and this wasn't gonna be a banger but
somebody else threw it before he didn't
he was like [ __ ]
goddammit you know that's people's joker
i told you i was gonna do that bro i
told you in the pen yesterday you don't
throw the [ __ ] jello
that's my [ __ ] t-bone don't play
[ __ ] dude that sucks yeah but he's he's
he's now free
just walking around so what do you think
he's gonna get it what do you think he's
gonna give it i guarantee he's gonna do
a podcast
really so cause nobody else is gonna put
him on anything else he's gonna do a
podcast
do you think his need to be like seen in
in the [ __ ]
like after all this you think he wants
to do a podcast sounds like an egomaniac
for sure
i don't i wouldn't be surprised i just
don't think he has much longer to live
to be would you listen to it yeah i
think so too of course i'm gonna listen
to his podcast i wanna see what this
[ __ ] maniac because i said yeah
so that's going to be like great talking
points for the podcast i want to see
like what he experiences
how do you feel about it today we're
going to discuss rape
there's a bunch of celebrities who have
personal stories about him and how he
would behave like crazy [ __ ] isn't that
crazy how like so long and i like
hollywood and all this stuff that it was
like a known thing
but it took hannibal burris to just
start saying [ __ ] it i'm gonna start
talking about it
[ __ ] this [ __ ] and he goes on and starts
talking about everyone's like yo
that is kind of [ __ ] up that he does
this [ __ ] let's get this [ __ ]
because he would
hannibal was mad that he told people to
like not cuss yeah which has been a
thing since eddie murphy
right but hannibal burst was like this
[ __ ] tell me to pull up my
pants it's like
how about you just not rape people
that's what blew it up that's like kind
of what blew it up and then people
started digging into it they're like oh
[ __ ]
there's a [ __ ] jello pudding pop
family guy type of dude he rapes
but isn't that crazy though like that
type of guy who's out here raping off
it's a power dynamic thing too and i
guarantee you it's not just bill cosby
bill cosby was the original virtue
signaler he was the original cancel
culture you know
yeah he's out here trying to cancel
everybody tell everyone
what to do but he's out here raping what
a meta what a great metaphor that's
so crazy you think you're so [ __ ]
cool he's the original sj person
you know bill cosby hey if you're sjw
out there you're just like bill cosby
that's true you know what i mean amen
anybody who defends bill cosby at this
point you're a piece of [ __ ] like
there's
absolutely no way you could and trust me
i defended him
super hard brought here rappers defend
him bro
there was a big boy song that i really
liked and i liked his boy
but he's like they're saying bill
cosby's a raping but
who knows what the truth is and it's
like nah man it's pretty
good who knows what the truth is bro
yeah it's like what's really consent
oh [ __ ] guys like what the hell's going
on teenage
yeah you never you ain't never had
non-consensual sex you ain't living
these rappers are [ __ ] nuts oh there
was a rapper that just
just shits like everyone can hear it you
know is this a chicago forever that came
out
of jail i think it was literally two
days ago
chief keef no no no no no no no no what
came out of jail
i think the same day he got shot 64
times
64 64 [ __ ] times literally gets out
of jail walks out and blasts him
64 times those people still aren't
caught
it's been like a couple days what do you
think it was for uh
he he talked about it he talked a lot of
[ __ ] he was very gang affiliated though
but this this gang [ __ ] doesn't stop man
i don't know why people
stop glorifying gangster you ain't about
that life like come on
it's like really about that gang life
you hear they have two years maybe three
years of just like good music whatever
they get really popular and then you
never hear from them again
dead they're i'd say it yeah that's
because yeah what the [ __ ]
the the dude that so we talked about it
on the other podcast the dude that was
murdered
uh in his um
in his car yeah so the the thing about
that is i heard he kept on defacing a
nipsey's
dipsy hustle's [ __ ] mural why did he
do that that's some gang [ __ ] or
whatever
so he was man he can't be doing that
[ __ ] so he had a hit on him that's like
what people are saying is like he kept
on he was the one that was defacing
this house wow [ __ ] man people love that
guy
people love nipsey for a good reason
nipsey for the screets bro yeah like he
seemed like a good news he was dope
though he was real [ __ ] cool that was
crazy that they
grinding all my life grinding all my
life
it's the remix 2 ignition yeah fresh out
of the kitchen
mama rolling that body got every man in
here
sipping on cooking i'm like so what i'm
drunk
it's the freaking weekend baby i'm about
to have some fun
for the kids
but that song is good and if you if it's
not either or right
it could be both true i believe i can
fly
i believe i can touch the sky
space jam i think about it every night
and day
i believe i can fly see
message dude messing around as [ __ ] yeah
i find the funniest part about
about that documentary is that after he
got out of prison the first time
the first thing he did he did he did a
drive-by snooping at an elementary
school yeah bro
what yeah he did what he went he drove
by elementary schools and it was like
kicking it
yo what's up he's like it's me your boy
r kelly you're blessed free i want to
thank all my fans
by the way who wants to come with you
this guy is the worst criminal ever dude
he just walked
he drove by elementary schools he was
like how old is you
she's like seven uh two old and he just
drove by
bro isn't that a reflection of the
justice system though it's like how do
these guys still keep getting off why
are they
next to an elementary school at all [ __ ]
this guy yeah right yeah like how are
these like rapists and all these
[ __ ] out here
snatching up little kids getting off but
people are in jail for the rest of their
life for marijuana
what's going on bro we gotta figure out
homeboy almost went to rikers for
[ __ ]
seven years right i'm not saying sorry
we're not apologizing to the [ __ ]
movie
dude he came out with a nice british
accent excuse me
i apologize and he goes like you know
what you're free r kelly
you are free too let's go boys everybody
like [ __ ] oprah oh my god well guys
that wraps up this episode of the genius
brain
it smells great i love it a lot stupid
alcohol [ __ ] me up man
dude i swear to god during this i saw
david just like slowly kind of
fall asleep while he's looking at me
while he's talking it wasn't even fall
asleep i was just like man
your boy faded i like your boy in
another universe
and i just started sobering up right now
[ __ ] man
but you can catch nick the ear at nick
the ear let's go
and you can find patrick dot t-dot riley
at patrick.t.r
stand up is back in pandemic is not over
but the stand-up's back in
let's go check him out his shows you can
get trained by [ __ ] nick cause i
think he knows what he's doing
sometimes though hit him up slide into
their dms ask him how dark his dong is
it's dark and he says dark it's dark
[ __ ] like jason cheney's y'all yeah
that's right
purple no veins let's go baby every
thursdays and sundays we'll see you all
next time
peace